[Musik]
im aargauischen wohlen ist ein ehepaar
in seiner villa erschossen worden
die umstände der tat sind so rätselhaft
dass wir entschlossen haben diesem fall
in einem beitrag nachzugehen
es ist dieses verbrechen das anfang 1991
das aargauische wohnen erschüttert das
ehepaar peter und ursula breit schmid
wird in seiner villa aus nächster nähe
erschossen kreis gar nicht richtig
realisiert was passiert ist und es ist
sehr steinig mit dem monat oktober nicht
ein richtig auch eine verkraften was
passiert ist ist ihnen ein schockzustand
war über mehrere monate lang hat das
headquarter die druck von einer
exekution
auf mich macht will dir beide doch schon
ältere personen eigene wohnzimmer mit je
zwei schuss aus nächster nähe gebracht
worden am anfang hat man zwei leichen
gefunden und so schweiß minute dann muss
man akribisch spurensuche und gerade dem
fall zeigt sich dass polizeiliche
ermittlungen beim englischen
detektivarbeit ist
[Musik]
es ist der elfte februar 1991 ein kalter
winterabend im aargauischen wohlen
das ehepaar peter und ursula breitschmid
verbringt den abend gemeinsam zu hause
in ihrer villa ihr 27-jährige
adoptivsohn romano lebt nicht mehr
daheim
er arbeitet als artist in spanien der
leibliche sohn christian steht kurz vor
der matura und jobs an diesem abend
während seiner schulferien in einer
videothek
[Musik]
gegen 22.30 kommt der 21 jährige
christian nach hause
doch an diesem abend ist die haustüre
verschlossen und ich bin hingegangen und
diakonischer stellt sie und beten ist
bei uns im wohnzimmer aber love und dann
wird das mein vater und meine mutter
mottolied es mir vor wie in einem
schlechten film also unrealistisch
gebieten geborgen und dem credo das
risiko laut lachen umgesehen und hat
ziemlich schnell realisiert dass das
dort sind also hurtig zerstören haben
polizei und ambulanz ableitet der mann
ist so halb und dem klub tisch liegt
gleich irgendwie druck kam der mann ist
sehr überraschend fand angriffe wurde
eine frau bei schmidt die ich im
wohnzimmer mit am boden gelagerte stroh
kritik sie die frauen operiert flüchten
gestellt dass die beiden personen mit
zwei kopfschüssen aus nächster nähe
gebracht urlaubs ganze zeit dass auch
durch gemacht dass das für die beiden
opfer sehr überraschend erfolgte ist
am tatort findet die polizei weder
fingerabdrücke noch einbruchspuren die
breit schmieds müssen den täter herein
gelassen haben raubmord fällt außer
betracht denn geld und wertsachen die
offen im haus herum lagen wurden keine
entwendet der vorerst einzige
anhaltspunkt mehrere augenzeugen haben
auf einem parkplatz in unmittelbarer
nähe des tatorts einen hellen renault 5
mit französischem kennzeichen gesehen
[Musik]
ganz holen ist geschockt das ehepaar
breitschmid war weit über die
dorfgrenzen hinaus bekannt und äußerst
beliebt
der 62 jährige peter breitschmid war
direktor der hofer kabel fabrik ein
familienunternehmen das sein vater
gegründet hatte
[Musik]
zudem sass er seit jahren im wohler
einwohnerrat und schrieb in seiner
freizeit für diverse zeitungen der
region
seine 58 jährige frau ursula war eine
angesehene fotografien und sozial sehr
engagiert
[Musik]
sie bezog zu schönen und zum guten und
zum vor allem aus dem schöne dem gewo
stumpe bewährt und gewalt gehabt
das ist für mich nix ii und ursula ich
ganz persönliche freundin von mir wo
nicht einfach mit reitern wo sie die
schwierigkeit mit dem roman und so
adoptivsohn romano ist das sorgenkind
der breitschmid der 27-jährige hat
ständig geldprobleme
die eltern unterstützen ihn finanzieren
[Musik]
romano ist ein begabter artist und
komiker er tingelt seit vier jahren mit
seinem 61 jährigen italienischen
bühnenpartner georgia durch die varietés
europas mit ihrem programm eine mischung
aus slapstick und akrobatik feiern die
zwei beachtliche erfolge
zur zeit des doppelmordes weilen sie in
der spanischen touristenhochburg
benidorm dem las vegas europas romano
und georgia haben dort ein engagement in
einer großen night show
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die erste nacht was passiert ist schon
ziemlich verhört haben das motto ruft
falle was ich mit den brüdern kontext
usa und über hat mit clark sie und
mitten im kühlen schatten hat weiß es
nur weil menschen baustoff ist auch mit
dem urlaub kommt zwar nicht zutraute
schon extrem gewaltlose manche opfer
sich wir krass klaus maier hat mich die
mixtur schnell co
und dann ist es komisch mail
benachrichtigen und handy nicht gleich
zwei mittag lagen noch dritter kann denn
das was im frühling motor erreicht und
hatte ihm das passiert ist er hat extrem
geschockt oder telefon und inhaber
sporttreff euro das der kollegen vor ihm
eben schon zwei tage vorher angeguckt
hat in der zeit hatten das ist für mich
nix was soll das also was passiert lucio
oder wunsch zurück und durchschnitt drei
tage später so revue passiert während
ich mich schon extrem komisch sie romano
kommt zwar aber erst am tag vor der
beerdigung seiner adoptiveltern
[Musik]
er wird unverzüglich von der
kantonspolizei aargau einvernommen
petri vernahm wo man einen roman breite
noch keine konkrete vorhalt gemacht
hätte darauf drängte sie ruhig gewirkt
auch sehr christina duxa dass der tod
vor seine adoptiveltern nicht sehr stark
beschäftigt hat und er hat jegliche
beteiligung an der tat als adoptiveltern
strikt tv sich die insel schmuck ch hat
deren zusammenbruch gerettet und
profiliert und den extremen gefühle
bewegende bis und haben in euphorie nach
romano wir sind übertraf somit zur
brücke mafia und sie haben mich
gezwungen und werkstoffe und und im
training gemerkt teilweise bis zum
tatort fragt und polizei hatten vorher
schon verhört
und da haben die gesagt hatte man ganze
polizei sagt dass unternehmen mehr -
auch nachdem die polizei lässt romano
noch an der beerdigung seiner
adoptiveltern teilnehmen unmittelbar
nach der trauerfeier wird wir jedoch
erneut einvernommen dem zweiten mal
hätten sie mal bei sich als opfer
darstellt indem externer partner ihn
bedroht wird in geldschwierigkeiten ist
sie die deka die ältere können wenn sie
trotz werbe und erhält der roman im
sinnvollen titel mafia betroffen hetze
probiert unter druck setze dass ich
allerdings sagen vom roman ob sie war
nicht sehr lang benötigte werkteile auf
polizei
nach dieser einvernahme wird romano
breitschmid in aarau in
untersuchungshaft gesetzt sein
bühnenpartner georgia es wird kurz
darauf in spanien verhaftet mit dem
verbrechen will er nichts zu tun haben
[Musik]
ursula und peter breitschmid lernen sich
in der 1950 er jahren kennen und
heiraten wald doch die ehe bleibt
kinderlos
[Musik]
1968 nimmt das paar den vierjährigen
romano zu sich und adoptiert ihn später
romano hat sein bisheriges leben in
einem schweizer kinderheim verbracht das
von nonnen geführt wurde
er ist eines der sogenannten kinder der
landstrasse das umstrittene projekt der
pro juventute nahm zwischen 1926 und
1973 fahrenden in der schweiz
systematisch die kinder weg und
platzierte diese in erziehungsanstalten
und kinderheimen rund 600 kinder waren
betroffen darunter roman der
gerichtspsychiater josef sachs hat
romano breitschmid im rahmen der
strafuntersuchung begutachtet über
romanus zeit im kinderheim hat der
widersprüchliches in erfahrung gebracht
dass er unbeschwert und auf der andere
seite juli trotz allem sicherheit zurück
blieben sicher schwer stört sie oder die
jetzt entwickelt und das ist für mich
dass er so wie zwei ec-karten und je
nach denen die eine oder andere seite
zeigen hätten vorstellig sieht das
zweite tor das erste roman josi und den
hunden zum romanik seiki zu sicht ist
zukünftige mami und das ist immer so ich
fahre das wollte und sympathisch 67 also
anzeige nicht jedes schicksal
romano entwickelt sich bei den
breitschmid zu einem herzigen
aufgeweckte bub und dann wird ursula
breitschmid und worauf doch noch
schwanger im januar 1970 kommt sohn
christian zur welt
mir ist ein großes vorbild wurde
bewundert habe das ursache sind wahr
gemacht hat als akrobaten und jongleure
und komiker und ich alle renova gerückt
die polizei ist auch monate nach dem
mord an peter und ursula breitschmid in
ihren ermittlungen nicht viel
weitergekommen
[Musik]
romano breit schmid sitzt nach wie vor
in untersuchungshaft und beharrt darauf
dass sein bühnenpartner george es einen
mafia killer angeheuert habe es dauert
sage und schreibe anderthalb jahre bis
romanos bühnenpartner georgias von
spanien an die schweiz ausgeliefert wird
das sicher bis sehr altmodisch und das
ist nur projekt für die zieht wo die
nationalstaaten 70 krimis trauer hand
und druckwerke analyt was er wird
ausgeliefert werden
das rechtsmittelverfahren wo sie über
mehrere instanzen auf achten dass sie
ausgeliefert werden
george s wehrt sich mit allen mitteln
gegen eine auslieferung auch als
indikators polizei aargau endlich von
spanien in die schweiz über stellen kann
leugnet er hartnäckig etwas mit der tat
zu tun zu haben
doch plötzlich gibt ihr eine beteiligung
zu er will jedoch nur als vermittler
zwischen roman und dem angeblichen
mafia-killer gewirkt haben und dann
bekommt auch diese einen namen georgias
bezichtigt seinen 53 jährigen bruder
ricardo den doppelmord am ehepaar
breitschmid begangen zu haben
ligator wird im sommer 1992 in spanien
verhaftet und sechs monate später an die
schweiz ausgeliefert
[Musik]
der adoptierte romano erlebt ihn wohl in
eine unbeschwerte kindheit
er ist zwar kein besonders gutes schüler
aber schon als kleiner junge artistisch
sehr begabt seine adoptiveltern peter
und ursula unterstützen und fördern ihn
wo sie nur können
als roman u17 wird bezahlen in die
eltern die artisten ausbildung an der
scuola teatro dimitri in verscio im
tessin
dort wird romanos talent offenkundig er
ist einer der begabtesten schüler
überhaupt nicht möglich sie hätte das
unglaublichste land kein akrobatik musik
also einfach völlig gesandt und und
frisch die bekannte saal akrobatin
mascha dimitri besuchte damals zusammen
mit romano die schule die ersten zwei
jahre ihre artisten ausbildungs und
mascha und romane unzertrennlich doch
dann beginnt romano sich zu verändern
sagt nicht sicher wie sich richtung dass
ich mit freunden im haar oder sich das
nicht mit dem teile so sehr wir wieder
zwei jahre und sich die zweifache
beunruhigung will ich mit über haus als
wenn ich starten will muss man sich dem
fall widmen und dann plötzlich sowie das
mittel bereits so einfach abprallen
romano nimmt die schule nicht mehr so
ernst und stürzt sich ins nachtleben von
ascona
er bekennt sich zu seiner homosexualität
wenig später erfährt er dass er hiv
positiv ist
so der roman erfahren hat und alles
gesprochen ist ich sehe meinen job der
familie gegangen
extrem schön ich ziehe mein vater wo
eigentlich ehre unsere konservative
richtig wurden das extrem micro hat und
dann auch eine extreme zusammenhalt
gespürt haben im brüder sind zusammen
konkreten projekt und das tatsächlich
noch ihr geld der reform und sich als
gespür für mich ist das familienfest hat
dort aus und da haben romano ganz klar
kommuniziert worden ist dass man wenn
sie oder wenn er vielleicht braucht das
kulturforum mit motorrädern und immer zu
ihm wird stormarner sieht das ganz
anders
er erzählt später seine eltern hätten
ihn nie richtig geliebt
[Applaus]
das lebensgefühl hätte die benachteiligt
das ist so
das ist sehr stark
[Applaus]
auf romanos großes talent wird 1987 auch
der italienische art ist und varieté
künstler giorgio aufmerksam
er bietet romano an mit ihm zusammen in
ganz europa aufzutreten
[Musik]
romanos eltern sind froh dass ihr
sorgenkind in viel älteren george so
einen erfahrenen bühne partner gefunden
hat
der dominante georgia ist der chef der
nummer
romano der heimliche star
[Musik]
romano führt ein wildes leben
seine gagen verpasst er in bars und
discos gilt als sehr spendabel romano
sucht die verwunderung will im
mittelpunkt stehen bringen ist es sehr
sehr wichtig sie dass er noch werk
zusätzlich zeigt die der art und weise
in der sich präsentiert hat wenn er sich
auch qualität wenn der kredit und er ist
auf der anderen seite hätte rooney
langfristige vertrauensvolle beziehung
zu anderen menschen vielleicht ist der
chat schon der einzige wo es nur über
eine gewisse zeit gegangen ist weil das
ihre dominante persönlichkeit sich aber
im allgemeinen ist er in der box wo über
einen gewissen stück weg von abo bezogen
wird beim kreis sondern das aber
verhindern gestanden hat und den die
florett romano ist ständig knapp bei
kasse und überhäuft seine adoptiveltern
mit geldforderungen
darum auch immer wieder mit
verschiedenen geschichte zum inhalt hat
irgendwie probierten verschiedene
projekte namensrecht frauen damals
kabarett nominell daran immer im zurück
liegenden wirtschaft merkbar cisco die
jungs machen und sie einen griechen zu
unterstützten
ein sportler sind auch hohe wurden
auftrag der betrag sie sind und mini
etwas komisch gefunden hat und dann auch
vorhersagen und das rohr machen oder ein
sehr auf ein komischer widerstand stoße
hatten besonders gesicherten rechten
blinker und hat mit dem für eine
richtige hand das wird den adoptiveltern
zum verhängnis es dauert vier jahre bis
das brutale verbrechen an peter und
ursula breitschmid zur anklage kommt
[Musik]
romano breitschmid ist bereits von aids
gezeichnet als 1995 in bremgarten der
prozess gegen ihn seinen italienischen
bühnenpartner georgias und dessen bruder
ricardo es beginnt das gericht muss
darüber befinden ob romane und georgia
die anstifter zum doppelmord an den
breitschmid sind und ob ricardo die tat
ausführte
eine schwierige aufgabe denn keiner der
angeklagten ist geständig
es ist ein reiner indizienprozess
[Musik]
ein indizienprozess dieter kann direkter
bewies sondern man muss verschiedene
informationen indirekt rückschlüsse dass
die daten so passiert ist das heißt man
braucht also verschiedene mosaiksteine
wo man am schluss rat zusammensetzen und
wo als bild erkannt wo es gericht kranz
wie viel mehr hat dass es sich so
abgespielt hat
und so soll es sich abgespielt haben
eines nachts nach einer vorstellung
romano ist betrunken und zornig dass
sein vater den geldhahn zugedreht hat
kurz zuvor wie romano erfahren haben
dass er einmal zwei millionen franken
erben wird im rausch fragt er george
aber nicht jemanden wisse der seinen
vater umbringen könnte georgio prallt er
kenne da jemanden von der mafia der
werde das sicher erledigen
vor gericht sagt georgia es aus sein
bruder ricardo habe sich bereit erklärt
peter breitschmid für 200000 franken zu
erschießen
gegenüber romano breitschmid habe er
immer nur von einem mafia killer
gesprochen
auch romano breitschmid beteuert er habe
nicht gewusst wer der killer ist
[Musik]
man muss nicht genau wisse wer die daten
nach russ führt als stifter langes wenn
man weiß welche konkrete person da wo
das dann soll umsätze und das hat er
immer gewusst will der george rating
seitlich an der eine und der ist bereit
für die 2
musik das mache das lange wenn ich als
aus stift der hinteren drei stifter das
weiß im frühjahr 1990 schließt romano
und giorgio einen brisanten vertrag ab
georgia soll romanos manager werden und
im gegenzug die hälfte von romanus
einkünften erhalten und nach rom alles
tot soll georgia dessen alleinerbe sein
vorerst ist davon die rede nur peter
breitschmid töten zu lassen
romano übergibt doktor zuhanden des
killers eine wegbeschreibung zum
elternhaus in wohlen und ein foto seines
vaters im mai 1990 fergies bruder
ricardo ein erstes mal nachholen
er verwechselt jedoch die villa der
bright schmitz mit dem benachbarten
altersheim später berichtet der georgio
er habe die tat nicht ausführen können
bei den breitschmid seien zu viele leute
gewesen
im herbst 1990 schlägt romano seinem
bühnenpartner georgia vor es sei doch
gescheiter wenn der killer gleich alle
töten
vater mutter bruder christian und die
großmutter dann würde das erbe auf einen
schlag viel größer ausfallen als die
vermuteten 2 millionen franken
[Musik]
als termin schlägt romano weihnachten
1990 vor
dann ist jeweils die ganze familie zu
hause in wohnen versammelt
vor gericht will sich romano breitschmid
an vieles nicht erinnern können
zudem betont er sei immer betrunken
gewesen wenn er mit george s über die
ermordung seiner familie gesprochen habe
er wüsste dass er deshalb bei der zeit
fiel auch konkret und mir wissen darum
dass unternehmen iv alkohol einen
technik stattfindend audiolith sind
enthält wenn sie auch grant in viele
ideen wo vorher bereits vorhandene
sender bewohnern gedroht dann kriminelle
zustand geschweige denn zwischen der
vlis sehr viel leichter im betrunkenen
zustand allerdings spielt das unsere
kleine rolle
je länger die längere zeit aus der
planungsphase von meinem sohn
identifizieren
die planung der tat zieht sich über ein
jahr hin
als es auf den vereinbarten ort termin
an weihnachten 1990 zugeht scheint sich
bei romano das gewissen zu melden
romano teil georgia mit der mord können
nicht stattfinden
er habe seine eltern angerufen und
erfahren dass an weihnachten sowieso
niemand zu hause sei die beiden kommen
überein den mord an romanos familie
abzublasen
sowohl romano breitschmid als auch
george s beteuert vor gericht sie hätten
den mordplan gestoppt der auftragskiller
ricardo es habe auf georgiers mitteilung
zwar wütend reagiert dass die eltern
breitschmid dann doch noch ermordet
wurden sei für romane und giorgio völlig
überraschend gekommen
[Musik]
wir verlangen
vielleicht jetzt noch merkt also wir mit
gefühlen richtig benutzen wir zugedeckt
worden wie nach rundungen und ich haben
die prozesse all die sachen sind mich
sehr rational abgelaufenen verwirrt
neutral sehen wirklich das sagen habe
und hoffe dass das gerichtsurteil findet
auch emotional ist mich wie rundungen
romano breitschmid sieht sich als opfer
von giorgis und behauptet er habe bei
der tatplanung nur auf dessen druck hin
mitgemacht jetzt nicht ganz genau wie
die dort plant wo denn ist die rede
magath wird sich die situation zu führte
und ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen
dass der roman arbeitslose dass er sehr
gerne sachen oft umwelt profitiert hat
sich in sachen aber letztlich steht vor
allem eine problematische situationen
sind dass er ist im hockey immer mehr
wünscht sich und er sich darum ein
richtiger später über themen wie viel
ist einfach schutzbehauptung das
bezirksgericht bremgarten glaubt romano
breitschmid nicht
die richter betrachten es als erwiesen
dass er seine ganze familie umbringen
lassen wollte um ans erbe zu kommen
dass christian die großmutter nicht
getötet wurden sei allein dem umstand zu
verdanken dass sie nicht anwesend war
romano breitschmid sei trotz seiner
beteuerung er habe den mordplan gestoppt
der anstifter zum verbrechen spricht das
aus meiner sicht richtig beurteilt der
roman hat es wenig macht um die dortige
200 müsse die opfer benachrichtigen oder
erhält müsse direkt probieren der killer
ruft halte und das ist nicht erkennbar
bühnenpartner georgia es gibt zwar eine
beteiligung zu er sei aber nur romanos
gehilfe gewesen und habe zwischen ihm
und seinem bruder ricardo dem kehler
vermittelt ricardo es streitet durchs
band ab etwas mit der tat zu tun zu
haben
doch er hat schlechte karten er weilt
anfangs februar 1991 zu besuch bei
seinem sohn im französischen an
dort mietet er bei europcar am morgen
des tattages einen weißen renault 5
[Musik]
genau einen solchen renault 5 mit
französischem kennzeichen haben zeugen
auf einem parkplatz in unmittelbarer
nähe der villa breitschmid gesehen
aus diesem grund fährt die
kantonspolizei aargau die strecke von
anssi nachholen und wieder zurück die
polizei misst dabei eine gefahrene
strecke von 6 138 km
das entspricht ungefähr der
kilometerzahl die europcar am tag nach
dem doppelmord dem tachometer des
mietautos von ricardo es entnimmt
[Musik]
ebenfalls schlecht für ricardo es sein
sohn sagt vor gericht aus sein vater sei
mit dem mietauto für zwei tage aus
anzieht verschwunden
ricardo es hat kein alibi doch er
leugnet hartnäckig weiter
das ist sexy
wo alles bestritten hat selbst sache wo
man im hemd schwarze beläge hätte
vorsicht gewisse nachher sogar behauptet
sie die unterlagen gefälscht roma neben
vorlegen sonst typische verhalten an und
versuche mit der polizei schon erfahrung
mit und weiß wie man das verhalten dass
möglichst wenig abgewiesen werden
das bezirksgericht bremgarten verurteilt
den hartnäckig leugnet in ricardo es
gestützt auf indizien
wegen mordes an peter und ursula
breitschmid und versuchten mordes an
christian und der großmutter zu
lebenslänglich gefängnis romanus
bühnenpartner georgias erhält wegen
anstiftung zum doppelmord an den
breitschmid und anstiftung zur
versuchten mord an christian und der
großmutter zwölf jahre gefängnis
romano breitschmid wird für dieselben
delikte zu 14 jahren gefängnis
verurteilt alle drei wollen das urteil
anfechten
christian breitschmid steht trotz allem
was passiert ist lange zu seinem bruder
roman um
er besuchte ihn auch regelmäßig im
gefängnis
[Musik]
dominiert von ihnen ältere frauen
dominierte kann ich das wort haus hat
existiert und ich haben immer kauft eine
alte mörder und der oman und der georgi
mit warum eigentlich eher mit leica und
ich das gefühl kaum unterstützung und
risiko von klar ist sehr viel absicht
der händler die unterschiede aber ein
böswilliger medizinischen mich oft sehr
schwierig sie will ehrlich immer nur für
sich genommen ist und hat allein das er
ab italien ist das mini eltern im land
und das militär
das nimmt da sind und da habe nicht
innerlich zerrissen die situation
möglich also mini extreme vermisst und
bremerhaven bremen nur das auch mich und
mir irgendwelche reue
da haben mich die bienen dran dran ist
oder aus dem weg und mit heidi wittmer
erteilte während 16 jahren den
gefangenen der strafanstalt lenzburg mal
unterricht zu ihr in den malkurs kam
auch romano breitschmid und kühl die
erlebnisse ob es schwierigste jahr der
neonazi-demo wort vor dem romano wärmt
vier jahrzehnte bevor sie mindestens
mehr die woche mit ihm zu konfrontieren
und mit dem bewusstsein erhält mini
beste veränderung braucht und mit der
gültigkeit der who und wie wenn das
überhaupt nicht passiert wäre also
irgendwann kaputt oder fisch märz weiter
verluste das ist lang einsetzen immer
wieder gesehen ist nicht unbegabt sie
keinen ausdrücke traum hätte das
selbstporträt gold da hat jemand große
afrika findet er dort können user setzen
von der leyen besiegte die an das sieht
nicht berührt wurde das delikt das ist
das hätte nicht wollen trainer
verarbeiten
romano breitschmid erlebt die
berufungsverhandlung nicht mehr
er stirbt kurz vor seinem 32
geburtstag in einem zürcher sterbehospiz
an aids
[Musik]
auch der erstinstanzlich verurteilte
mörder ricardo es stirbt vor der
berufungsverhandlung 1995 nimmt er sich
im gefängnis das leben
es wird rechtskräftig verurteilt er
sitzt seine strafe in der schweiz ab und
wird danach des landes verwiesen
er stirbt 2008 im alter von 78 jahren
[Musik]
das grab seines bruders besucht
christian breitschmid zum ersten mal
er hätte vor 13 jahren gerne an romanos
beerdigung teilgenommen
doch ihm wurde damals mitgeteilt dass er
unerwünscht sei
romano und ist nehmen sie 16 ist es
ruhig geworden um eine szene macht es
mich traurig wild romano extrem filter
lang hat nur so viel es sind auch keine
machen
jetzt liegen wir dafür gibt es ist sehr
viel talent verloren gegangen mit dem
ball gleich sind ist richtig gold
stromer knox college habe man das immer
gewünscht hat und leider anders geendet
[Musik]
18 jahre sind seit dem mord an seinen
eltern vergangen christian breitschmid
hat mit der vergangenheit abgeschlossen
doch vor kurzem hat er etwas erfahren
peter breitschmid war nicht sein
leiblicher vater er konnte es gar nicht
sein denn er war zeugungsunfähig
[Musik]
ursula breitschmid hatte im frühling
1969 einer affäre nur ihr ehemann peter
und wenige verwandte wussten davon
[Musik]
der fahrer das taxi ist ich verdiene
mein trick konfus sie normal ist das
nicht die ganze geschichte wiederum ist
eine schöne sache
doch nur familie hat auch ein vater wie
die ganzen tag nach dem vorfall am 26
nach der matura gemacht habe und ich
habe mir geht oder recherchieren aber
ich bin schnell auf kranzegg sicherlich
die musik und das er architektur
studiert hat in theorie und mini mutter
verhältnisse hat und somit das knie
er weiß nicht einmal den namen seines
leiblichen vaters
[Musik]
christian breitschmid hat heute selber
einen sohn
umso mehr hofft er dass er seinen vater
bald findet
[Musik]